we've talked before about the kentucky
senate race a longtime republican
senator and current senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
has a real challenge uh in former marine
and democratic nominee amy mcgrath they
recently debated
and disgusting mitch mcconnell just
laughing
cackling when amy mcgrath confronted him
about his
abject failures in dealing with
coronavirus
he just laughs he's laughing as more
than two hundred thousand have died take
a look at this
the house passed a bill in may
and and this the senate went on vacation
i mean you just don't do that you
negotiate senator it is a national
crisis
you knew that the coronavirus wasn't
going to end at the end of july
we knew this i mean i just think you've
got to
and here's the thing if you want to call
yourself a leader so bill you
you if you want to call yourself a
leader you got to get things done and
those of us who served in the marines we
don't just point fingers at the other
side
we get the job done senator you went on
vacation
when people needed coronavirus relief
[Laughter]
quite a guy right i mean we we have to
assume
i i really believe in giving people the
benefit of the doubt and i know there
are every state has a lot of ideological
nutty right wingers we have to assume
that not all kentuckians actually like
mitch mcconnell don't we in other words
part of why mitch mcconnell has been in
power for so long
has to be that many people simply aren't
paying attention and don't
actually endorse this guy's complete and
total immorality i hope for the sake of
humanity
that that's the case at least to some
extent here's more of mitch mcconnell
laughing off accurate statements from
amy mcgrath
about the supreme court about
coronavirus relief about everything
this montage includes part of the clip i
showed you just a couple minutes ago
and he's walking away from negotiations
even now
when president trump even wants
negotiations to happen before this
election
it's it's irresponsible senator
mcconnell
and instead of doing that he is trying
to ram through a supreme court nominee
right now
instead of negotiating which is what he
should have been doing
all summer long to make that happen
senator you have an additional response
we've got to get our democracy working
because we have to get through this
crisis right now that's your time
senator mcconnell
well senate went on vacation
i mean you just don't do that you
negotiate
senator it is a national crisis you knew
that the coronavirus wasn't going to end
at the end of
july if you want to call yourself a
leader you got to get things done and
those of us that served in the marines
we don't just point fingers at the other
side
we get the job done is it all a joke to
mitch mcconnell
or or does he at least see amy mcgrath
as a joke
is that what it is because that's the
laugh of a hypocrite
unfortunately there are many voters in
kentucky
who think at least he's not a democrat
and they're going to vote for him
that counts for a lot in many republican
strongholds like kentucky but
imagine removing mitch mcconnell on
november 3rd
it's an uphill battle no doubt but if
you look at 538.com
it says mcconnell has a 96 chance of
being re-elected
the truth is we don't have very recent
polling in kentucky
if you look at the polls on real clear
politics you'll see the latest poll
is nearly a month old yes mcconnell was
leading by 12 then
but that was a month ago a lot has
happened since then it could be six
right now within three weeks
it could be less than six we just have
no idea
and it's a great race to get involved in
and then briefly just as a reminder
south carolina incumbent republican
senator lindsey graham
has a serious challenge from democratic
candidate jamie harrison harrison has
been raising
ungodly amounts of money lately but the
concern is
how much of the money is from around the
country rather than from
voters in south carolina but the latest
polls there are good for harrison
in the last month the polls are a tie
lindsey graham ahead by one and two more
ties
if you go beyond that you're looking at
polling from july very
important race i think harrison has more
of a shot than mcgrath
but both really key races that you can
get yourself involved in
phone banking uh door-to-door
campaigning if you live in the states
and you can do it safely
etc get involved get involved and we are
going to talk on today's bonus show
about some of these races and more as
well
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming
a member at joinpakman.com we'll see you
then
every single day the trump
administration
shows us what happens when anti-science
christian conservatives have power in
government
on everything from climate change to
fighting this pandemic
we cannot afford another four years of
donald trump one of our sponsors today
is the free thought equality super pac
both they and i want to remind you that
voting against donald trump in the
presidential election
is one of the most important things you
can do right now if you want
religious conservatives to have less
power and you want science to have more
influence in government
make sure you're registered to vote make
the commitment to vote
on or before november 3rd i also
encourage you to check out the center
for free thought equality
which is an advocacy group that promotes
evidence-based public policy
and supports secular candidates running
for office becoming a member is
completely free
gives you access to tons of excellent
resources related
to secularism in politics just visit
cfequality.org
you can find the link right underneath
this video this message
was paid for by the free thought
equality super pac
and is not authorized by any candidate
or candidates committee